ça va pas
recommencer dégage bouffon surveille ton
langage c'est qui c'est la reine Regina
George la regarde pas dans les yeux tu
pourrais être grave fraîche si tu
changeais genre tout en
fait bienvenue au cours de santé et vie
sexuelle en préliminaire nous parlerons
d'abstinence puis au semestre prochain
de préservatif et de strangulation je ne
peux pas t'enseigner est ce que tu es en
train d'apprendre chérie tout va bien
là-dedans on avait peur que tu sois en
train de te droguer ou TUAC couché dans
les toilettes
dégueu en tant que femme nous devons
apprendre à nous entraider viens Luse
bienvenue Ky tu devineras jamais ce que
j'ai trouvé ce matin ton burnbook maman
on a la dalle oui chérie je vous apporte
quelque chose
ouais tu aimes les chewinggum ouais non
j'en ai pas je disais juste ça pour pour
tu es perdu ma pauvre on est là pour
toi pourquoi tu as un costume aussi
flippant c'est Halloween si tu te
déguises pas en chudass c'est comme si
tu nous jugeais c'est pas
professionnel c'est quoi ce truc
elle va nous le
payer tout ce qu'on a fait c'est la
rendre plus canon et relancer le wet
look
dancebreak qui a écrit ces vacheries
[Musique]
Ky l'
poussé
[Musique]
AZ
ça je m'appelle Inc il faut un prénom
françaison